Tous les Palestiniens,
pour les ukrainiens comme pour les Palestiniens,
nous sommes le vent de la
paix.
La paix est 1 idéal qui nous fait tenir
et qui nous porte
parfois au-delà de ce que l'on pourrait espérer.
Des colère digne et légitime des peuples opprimés
peuvent jaillir les plus belles désespérances.
Insoumis en soumise,
mes camarades,
mes chers amis,
nous avons raison d'espérer.
Oui, nous avons raison d'espérer du meilleur
pour nous sauver du pire de quelques ans.
Se battre pour les droits de chacune et de chacun,
c'est beaucoup sauver ce que nous avons en commun,
notre humanité.
Nous sauverons cette humanité
que si et seulement si
nous sauverons l'idéal d'un monde de paix,
ce monde qui dépend de nous et dont nous dépendons.
Parler de paix
nous engage surtout à faire la paix.
Et faire la paix
demande bien du courage.
C'est-ce courage qui isole
toutes celles et ceux
qui se lèvent face à 1 assemblée d'assis,
genoux jusqu'aux dents,
frappées par l'immobilisme.
La paix est 1 programme politique
en soi et c'est le Nord